[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí a América este es
el magazine de France 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden da un paso histórico en
la llamada guerra contra las drogas y
anunció un indulto para los condenados a
nivel Federal por posesión de marihuana
y ordenó que se excluya del grupo de
sustancias duras donde convive con la
heroína o con el LCD más de 500.000
personas fueron arrestadas en todo
Estados Unidos por delitos relacionados
con el cannabis en 2019 y Mientras tanto
en México la violencia de los cárteles
del narcotráfico estremece un grupo de
sicarios tomó la sede de la alcaldía de
un municipio en el Estado de Guerrero
Donde está ubicado el célebre balneario
de Acapulco al menos 20 personas
murieron entre ellas el alcalde
y en Brasil los dos candidatos que
quedaron en tercer y cuarto lugar en la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales le dieron su apoyo al ex
presidente de izquierda Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva sobre el actual mandatario
de ultraderecha Yair bolsonaro les
contamos Cómo se mueven las alianzas de
Cara a la segunda vuelta del 30 de
octubre pero vamos de inmediato a
Estados Unidos para nuestra historia
principal el presidente Joe biden
anunció que Perdona todas las condenas
federales leves por posesión de
marihuana el anuncio se da a un mes de
las elecciones de medio término en la
que los demócratas podrían perder la
mayoría en el congreso y allana el
camino hacia la despenalización total
del uso de Cannabis en el país que de
hecho ya es legales muchos estados 37
han aprobado su uso médico y entre ellos
19 su uso recreativo esta decisión
probablemente tendrá repercusiones en la
guerra contra las drogas en toda la
región veamos más en el informe de
Manuela Cano
un paso hacia la despenalización en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
anunció que indultará a los condenados
por delitos federales relacionados con
la posesión de marihuana en primer lugar
voy a perdonar todos los delitos
federales anteriores de Posesión simple
de marihuana hay miles de personas que
fueron condenadas previamente por
posesión simple y a las que se les puede
negar el empleo la vivienda o las
oportunidades educativas como resultado
mi indulto eliminará esta carga
la medida no cubre cargos relacionados
con la producción o posesión de
marihuana con la intención de
distribuirla y además aplica únicamente
a condenas federales sin embargo el
mandatario hizo un llamado para que los
gobernadores den el mismo paso hacia el
perdón de los delitos estatales para
muchos analistas se trata de una
decisión con fines electorales A pocas
semanas de unas elecciones de medio
término en las que los demócratas se
arriesgan a perder sus estrechas
mayorías legislativas es parte de una
batería de medidas y además de
legislaciones que el presidente ha ido
tomando enfocándose en grupos que yo
pienso que a los demócratas consideran
que son todavía gananciables en el marco
de la acumulación de apoyo electoral
creo que se ve en forzados ante la nueva
crecida del costo de los combustibles
ante los nuevos efectos de las medidas
fijadas por la OPEP a improvisar algunas
medidas que tienden yo creo que a tocar
sectores electorales que los cuales el
voto demócra se concentra en este caso
la población afroamericana la
legislación sobre el consumo y posesión
de marihuana en Estados Unidos está
cambiando rápidamente ya son 19 los
estados en los que su uso medicinal y
recreacional es totalmente legal El
último en añadirse al grupo fue
Connecticut en junio algunos estados
como Minnesota Missouri o Florida
aceptan su uso únicamente medicinal
mientras que esta sigue siendo ilegal en
Idaho Wyoming Kansas y Carolina del Sur
y Mientras tanto en México un grupo de
sicarios tomó la casa del presidente
municipal de San Miguel de totolapan en
el Estado de Guerrero Donde está ubicado
el célebre balneario de Acapulco y
asesinó al menos 20 personas entre ellas
el mismísimo alcalde Conrado Mendoza
almeda El presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador aseguró que está tratando de
atender las causas del mortal ataque
armado pero responsabilizó a los
gobiernos anteriores al aludir a las que
llama políticas neoliberales haciendo
alusión a su vez a la llamada guerra
contra las drogas iniciada por el ex
presidente Felipe Calderón cuando llegó
al palacio del Zócalo en 2006 escuchemos
las palabras del actual mandatario
el caso
totolapan
son organizaciones
que vienen de tiempo atrás
no surgieron En este gobierno
y estamos buscando
atender las causas
sin embargo veamos precisamente la cifra
de la semana tras el asesinato de
Conrado Mendoza almeda 18 alcaldes han
muerto en hechos violentos Durante los
casi cuatro años de mandato de Andrés
Manuel López Obrador según un recuento
de la consultora etelec que agrega
además que durante este periodo
presidencial se ha registrado un 25% más
de asesinatos de políticos que durante
todo el mandato de Calderón quien
gobernó México de 2006 a 2012
y de hecho no es la primera vez que la
sede de las autoridades locales de San
Miguel de totolapan es atacada al menos
tres veces ha sido blanco de grupos
armados incluso con granadas con apenas
20.000 habitantes es un bastión del
crimen organizado y donde se produce y
se traslada a droga por el corredor del
Pacífico hacia Estados Unidos vamos a
Ciudad de México con nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonell Mario
explícanos por favor el contexto de este
municipio
Tierra Caliente es una región en México
que comprende varios municipios de tres
estados del área centro Pacífico se
trata de los estados de Guerrero
Michoacán y el estado de México es una
zona que se caracteriza por una
importante actividad agrícola y Ganadera
pero también por ser una ruta
estratégica para el trasiego de drogas
como la marihuana y la amapola hacia
Estados Unidos es una zona donde ha
imperado el crimen organizado de grupos
delictivos como el de la Familia
Michoacana que se dedican al cobro de
secuestros extorsiones y derecho de piso
así como de homicidios hay municipios
como Coyuca de Catalán en Guerrero donde
la población refiere que el crimen
mantiene el control en todas las
actividades incluido el transporte
público y el comercio también hay una
ola de asesinatos recientes de líderes
ecologistas en la tierra caliente de
Guerrero que defienden el bosque de la
tala clandestina todos estos delitos han
provocado un fenómeno de desplazamiento
interno forzado organizaciones
en el centro de derechos humanos de la
montaña tlachinolan así como la comisión
mexicana para la defensa y promoción de
derechos humanos han documentado el
desplazamiento interno forzado de cerca
de 4000 personas en distintos municipios
de la Tierra Caliente
recientemente en municipios como San
Miguel totolapan donde ocurrió un multi
homicidio que acabó con la vida del
alcalde y rompió de nueva cuenta otro
grupo delincuencial denominado Los
Tequileros que tuvo su auge en el año
2016 y que en 2018 tras la muerte de su
líder raibel Jacobo de Almonte se
parecía extinguido no obstante de nueva
cuenta ha irrumpido en la escena pública
a través de un video en redes sociales
donde anuncia su regreso y en Ecuador la
violencia carcelaria volvió a recrudecer
esta semana con dos reyertas en tres
días que dejaron Al menos 29 presos
asesinados y 59 heridos la mayoría de
este tipo de altercados es entre bandas
criminales que disputan el control
interno de los carcelarios desde donde
operan carteles del narcotráfico
y nos vamos a Brasil donde en menos de
una semana se formaron las alianzas de
Cara a la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales el presidente
Yair bolsonaro recibió el apoyo de los
tres gobernadores de los estados más
grandes del país Mientras que el
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
fue respaldado por los dos candidatos
que quedaron en tercer y cuarto lugar
veamos más en el siguiente informe que
preparamos para ustedes
un espaldarazo clave si montebet la
tercera candidata más votada en la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil le dio su apoyo
al ex presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva para el balotaje la senadora del
partido de Centro derecha movimiento
democrático brasilero dijo que se
adhiere al expirante de izquierda debido
a que reconoce su compromiso con la
democracia a diferencia del actual
mandatario de ultraderecha Yair
bolsonaro mi apoyo a Lula no es por
adhesión mi apoyo es por un Brasil que
sueño sea para todos incluyente generoso
sin hambre y sin miseria con educación y
salud de calidad con desarrollo
sostenible si bien tvt solo obtuvo el
4,2% de los votos su apoyo es clave Pues
solo cinco votos porcentuales separaron
a Lula de bolsonaro en la primera vuelta
Lula da Silva también recibió el apoyo
del candidato Ciro Gómez del partido
democrático laborista cuarto en las
elecciones con 3,5 millones de votos
por su parte el presidente Yair
bolsonaro ya ha recibido el apoyo de los
gobernadores de los tres estados más
poblados de Brasil Rodrigo García de Sao
Paulo Romeo cema de minas geray y
Claudio Castro de Río de Janeiro en sus
colegios electorales votan 63 millones
de electores de los 156 del país
mientras serán los movimientos políticos
los candidatos buscan los votos
religiosos bolsonaros en una iglesia
evangélica
doy gracias a Dios por mi familia mi
segunda oportunidad en la vida en mi
misión y con las personas a mi lado
Lula por su parte se acercó a la iglesia
católica
el Papa Francisco ha sido un hombre de
valor ejemplar
el nuevo presidente saldrá de la
votación en segunda vuelta del 30 de
octubre
y vamos a Bolivia donde varias obras
inconclusas durante la gestión Evo
Morales se han convertido en un problema
para el actual gobierno de Luis Arce que
tras dos años en el poder no ha podido
reactivarlas nuestra corresponsal en La
Paz merivaca nos explica
la comunidad indígena de copacate en el
municipio de Copacabana situado en la
frontera de Bolivia con Perú vive junto
a un aeropuerto inaugurado hace cuatro
años que no está operativo la obra es
considerada por los habitantes de la
zona como un elefante blanco sin
beneficio alguno y queremos de una vez
que lleguen los avionetas y también que
ya trabajen de una vez que la empresa
cualquier empresa nosotros cuidemos aquí
la terminal aérea pensada para atraer el
turismo desde Perú tiene una pista de 2
kilómetros y costó 6.5 millones de
dólares el diputado opositor Miguel roca
que visitó el lugar asegura que la obra
construida en la gestión de Evo Morales
estaba destinada a ser un fracaso porque
nunca tuvo un estudio de factibilidad
comercial tenemos igual que este el de
el aeropuerto de itziamas y el
aeropuerto de Apolo no funcionan no
llegan vuelos y es por una lógica de el
modelo Como dijo Evo Morales yo le meto
nomás otras construcciones similares son
el museo dedicado a Evo Morales que
costó 5.6 millones de dólares y está
cerrado y la sede del parlamento de
unasur de 72 millones de dólares que
nunca abrió sus puertas el ministro de
economía de que no se reactivarán las
obras que se han insostenibles y agregó
que el presidente Luis Arce ahora es
riguroso para aprobar nuevos proyectos
porque se está haciendo una evaluación
muy rigurosa y detallada para que no
ocurran ningún tipo de problemas
relacionado a una asignación ineficiente
que al final no tiene un uso ningún
beneficio por la sociedad al margen de
esa polémica los pobladores de
Copacabana continúan reclamando que se
abran las operaciones del aeropuerto
para que aumente el turismo junto al
lago titicaca necesario para el sustento
de la comunidad
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Luis Fernando Montes
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web tras 24.com y Para
más información de nuestro continente
Sigan viendo France 24
[Música]